TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello, and
welcome to the Developer Show.
Remember to use the
nav bar at the bottom
to skip to your favorite
topic at any point.
Now let's start with the TLDR.
Use the Unity game engine
to build games for the TV
with the new Google Cast Remote
Display plug-in for Unity.
The Google Cast
Remote Display APIs
use the powerful GPUs, CPUs, and
sensors of your Android or iOS
mobile device to render a local
display on your mobile device
and a remote display on your TV.
Leon is going to join
us later on the show
to give us more details.
LEON NICHOLLS: Great to be here.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Learn how
to build, update, and use
containers on the Google Cloud
Platform with this tutorial
by Julia Ferraioli.
It's a four-part series of
blog posts that gives you
a great hands-on
introduction using
something familiar to many of
us, running a Minecraft server.
I know it's familiar
to all of us.
Build powerful applications that
can see and, more importantly,
understand the
content of images.
This functionality is now
available in the Google Cloud
Vision API.
Rob Craft is on the show
today to tell us more.
ROB CRAFT: Thanks for having me.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Tap4Fun
increased their game's rating
of a 4.0 by using
the review system
to address user problems,
as well as beta testing
to improve the
quality of their games
from within the Google
Play Developer Console.
Find out how in this video
with Tap4Fun's CEO, founder,
and their creative director.
Learn more about the
improvements to Sign-In
with Google with this
latest post in a series
by Laurence Moroney.
He talks about changes
to basic sign-in flow,
silent sign-in, and
customizing the Sign-In button.
Understand what users' Google
searches drive into your app,
as well as how
those users behave
once they're in your app using
Deep Link Referrer Analytics.
Hey, a new version of
Chrome, just like clockwork.
The latest beta includes Present
to Cast, custom notification
buttons, and network estimation.
The Google Maps SDK
for iOS has been
updated to include bit
code support, new events,
and some features
previously only available
in the Android SDK.
All that and more today
on the Developer Show.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's start the show
by talking about games.
Leon Nicholls, a developer
programs engineer
worked on the Google Cast Remote
Display plug-in for Unity.
Leon, welcome to the show.
LEON NICHOLLS: Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So tell
us a little bit what
is the plug-in, maybe what is
Unity for those few people that
don't know what it is, and
a little bit about the API
for Google Cast, the
remote display API.
LEON NICHOLLS: OK.
So Unity is a very popular game
engine used by a lot of games.
And what we launched
last week was a plug-in
that allows you to take our
remote display technology
and take your game, your mobile
game, and make it run on a TV.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
So you already got a mobile
game running on Unity,
and you just sort of expand
that into the living room.
LEON NICHOLLS: That's right.
ROB CRAFT: So you're
curing my back problems--
LEON NICHOLLS: Yeah.
ROB CRAFT: [INAUDIBLE].
Nice.
LEON NICHOLLS: We'll see.
ROB CRAFT: Nice.
LEON NICHOLLS: So this is great
for the living room, right.
You can take your existing
game and just add the plug-in
and use our technology
to render that on the TV.
And we support all the popular
platforms, Android and iOS.
And it's really
easy to integrate.
So we've launched a sample
[? app. ?] We've also launched
a [? code ?] [? lab ?], and some
updates to our UX guidelines
to make sure that you
create a great Cast game.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Great.
So, one last thing is about
the Cast Remote Display APIs.
And I think something
people might not
know is the real power of
these, aside from just taking
your existing came and kind
of expanding it to the TV,
not having to learn
a new thing, is
you get to take advantage of
all the hardware on the phone.
LEON NICHOLLS: Yes.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
So you don't have
to rely on the hardware of
whatever Google Cast device
you might be using, but
rather the GPUs and the CPUs
in the phones that
people are upgrading
every year or two anyway.
LEON NICHOLLS: Yes.
So you can now render great
animation, great graphics,
great sound, and put that on
a very low-end Cast device
like a Chromecast.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
All right.
Thanks, Leon.
Have you ever wondered how
you can use notifications
to build a deeper
relationship with your user
instead of pushing them away?
I caught up with Chris Wren at
the Android Developer Summit
to learn how.
Hi, there.
I'm sitting here
with Chris Wren.
He's a staff software
engineer here at Google,
although if you looked
at his business card,
it would say maker.
CHRIS WREN: It does.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Because
you make things.
CHRIS WREN: Because I
make things, that's right.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Today we can
talk a little bit about making
things with notifications.
You gave a talk here at Android
Dev Summit about notifications.
You should check it
out for more info.
But there's a couple things
I wanted to touch upon,
first of which-- and I think
this gets glossed over when
developers start to think
about notifications,
is like why do they care?
CHRIS WREN: I think
what developers
don't think about is
that notifications
are the first place often the
users come into their phone.
And that's your
opportunity to build trust,
to deliver information
that they need
and they can act
upon, and not just do
something that's obviously
for your own benefit
and the benefit of your app.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So it's
about building trust
in a relationship
with the user, really.
CHRIS WREN: Yeah, I think so.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So when
you think about, like,
the notifications that
you give your user,
you shouldn't just
think about how do I,
like, uptick that graph of
user attention, like entry.
I mean, because one of
the things you talk about
in your talk is that
uninstalling an app
is really only a click away.
CHRIS WREN: Right.
If you're not delivering
value to the user,
then why are you there?
Why are you in my pocket?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
So--
CHRIS WREN: So imagine
an SMS app that said hey,
you'll never guess what
message you just got.
That would be terrible.
You would install that,
like, in an instant.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And what would
be the better alternative
than the SMS app there?
CHRIS WREN: Well obviously,
you should give the user
the information they need.
Like, don't tease them.
Like, show them the message.
Maybe even give them
some actions about,
oh, I don't need to
deal with this now.
Like, snooze.
Tell me that later or something.
Let them get on with their life.
Let them manage their life.
They'll come back if
they're happy with the app.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Everybody,
please check out
Chris's excellent
talk on notifications
so that you can build a great,
trustworthy relationship
with your user from the get-go.
Thanks, Chris.
CHRIS WREN: Thanks.
Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Next on the show,
let's talk about the
Cloud Vision API.
Rob Craft, a products manager
for the Google Cloud platform,
joins us on the show today.
ROB CRAFT: Great to be here.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So let's talk
about the Cloud Vision API.
Now, in particular, we recently
announced this and the internet
is abuzz with excitement.
I mean, the Cloud Vision
API is a really awesome tool
for developers.
First, I'd love to
know a little bit more
about the technology behind it
and what it gives developers,
and then move into
talking about use cases.
What can be done with this API?
ROB CRAFT: So Vision API you
can look at as a very easy way
to use machine learning to
do a whole different class
of application.
So machine learning is all
about training models, forming
models, massaging
data for models.
There's models, is
what I'm getting at.
So inside of that space,
there's a lot of PhDs,
there's a lot of lab coats.
Frankly, at Google,
we spend a lot of time
building out
infrastructure for it.
Vision API makes it very simple.
You send us an
image, we send you
back what you asked
for, whether it
was sentiment analysis
on who's smiling or not
smiling in the photo,
what is actually there,
like all the way down
to genus of plant
sometimes, what the
composition of the photo
is-- it a happy space,
an unhappy space--
those sorts of things
that we think really
transform what a
developer can do today
versus what they used to do.
A great scenario that we
talked about a couple of times
is the idea of if you're
shooting video for a show,
you might have the
opportunity to say, well,
I don't want to have to go
through and manually plumb who
or where people were
in a particular shot,
or what was on stage
at a particular time.
It'd be great if I
were able to feed
keystone images
into a system and it
spits it back out for me.
Because imagine you're running
commercials for 50 shows
a week.
It's a workload that isn't
all that interesting.
So how do we fix that for you.
So the Vision API really enables
that across a lot of new areas.
There's tons of amazing
scenarios coming.
So it's going to be really
interesting in six months
when people are done.
LEON NICHOLLS: So this is
great for app developers
like me, because if I have
to make sense of an image,
I don't really know
where to begin.
So now you're telling me Google
will just do that work for me?
That's really great.
ROB CRAFT: The trick
inside of the box
is we keep it out
of your vision.
So we want to make
it very simple.
So machine learning
is a tough space.
It's hard to simplify
too much about losing
the baby and the bathwater.
We want to make it just
very, very simple for you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You
know, this is something
we were talking about before
the show, which I think
is really interesting
when you look
at machine learning
and its growing
popularity in the
developer space,
I think a big part of that is
that it's becoming accessible,
that APIs and tools
are coming out
to allow developers to
integrate this in their app
without the PhD in cognitive
sciences and mathematics
to be able to build these
things from the ground up.
ROB CRAFT: Yep.
The core technologies that come
from our own research group
have been used in other areas
inside of Google for a while.
And how we optimize
our own business,
like Search or
Photos, do a great job
of taking the tensor flow
kind of modeling capabilities
and using it to solve
our own problem set.
We're in the cloud platform
business in Google Cloud,
so we try to make it
simple for everybody else
to get the same experience,
and tooling it down
to a level where you don't have
to have your PhD in the space
really makes the difference.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Thanks.
Thanks, Rob.
ROB CRAFT: Sure.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
Let's get to the final
question of our show, which
is how will you use the Google
Cloud Vision API to make
your holidays better.
And extra points for silliness.
ROB CRAFT: So there's the
Charlie Brown Christmas, right.
Everyone knows this.
So, are the children really
that depressed and unhappy?
Let's see what Vision
API has to say.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
Leon.
LEON NICHOLLS: So, OK, this
might be a bit serious,
but I think I'm going to use
the Vision API to let Google
watch movie trailers
for me and then tell me
which movies to watch.
Am I going to watch
the "Star Wars"
movie or the "Chipmunks" movie?
It comes out on the same day.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: They
come out on the same day?
How are we going to decide?
ROB CRAFT: Doubleheader.
LEON NICHOLLS: Don't know.
ROB CRAFT: Clearly
a doubleheader.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right,
guys, thanks for joining us
on the show today.
LEON NICHOLLS: Sure.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hey,
you've got questions.
Turns out we've got
answers in our new segment
called Ask Dev Show.
This isn't a selfie stick.
It's an answer
machine for questions
that only a Googler can answer.
Ask me almost anything in the
comments or on social media,
and I'll get you your answer.
Smash on Twitter asked
if I could find out
what's in the box.
Reto.
RETO: Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
This is your office.
RETO: This is
absolutely my office.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: This
is not your office.
RETO: This is
completely my office.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Nothing
is plugged in down there,
and you're watching cat videos.
RETO: Uh-- how can I help you?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Maybe
it is your office.
What's in the box?
RETO: Which box?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That
box right there.
RETO: Oh.
The Android Studio Box.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yes.
RETO: Android Studio 2.0--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Shiny.
RETO: Right on top here.
Instant Run.
New Emulator. [INAUDIBLE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What's
that in the corner there?
Oh, that's--
RETO: Uh, that's--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Can
we-- that's pretty-
RETO: That's not important.
No, you don't have to-- don't
have to worry about that.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: We can't
talk about that yet?
RETO: We can't talk about that.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
Well, that's what's in the
box, or at least as much
as we can talk about.
[MUSIC PLAYING]